As a developer,
your goal is to keep your app
rendering at 60 frames per second.
This means that you have 16 milliseconds
to finish all of your computation and
drawing for the next frame.
If you miss the 16 millisecond target,
you'll have a dropped frame,
which will cause your app to skip.
So, you'll want to use this time wisely.
A common you've probably
encountered is overdraw.
The idea here is that you draw a layer.
Great.
But then the next layer you draw
obscures a portion of
that initial layer.
You just wasted precious time drawing
all of those pixels that were drawn over
immediately after.
There are two ways to
tackle overdraw issues.
The first is to remove
unnecessary backgrounds and
drawables, such as a base white
background on your top most layer
when you're completely obscuring
the layer out with other views.
Or you can mark certain portions of
the layer as visible or not visible.
Especially with stacked views, this
will help by only drawing the visible
portions and
ignoring the rest until it's needed.